how's it helping women when the taxes
are so high they have to go to work
because we got to pay for all the
illegals I'm at the California GOP
convention folks I'm a conservative but
at this point do cares we got to
straighten out the country and you know
what I'm done listening to this guy I
want to talk to the ladies there are a
lot of them here
half of Republican women say they can't
see themselves voting for Trump I found
a lot here who would do you feel that
Donald Trump appeals to female voters
absolutely are you bothered at all by
some of the things Donald Trump has said
about women specifically you know you
could see there was blood coming out of
her eyes blood coming out of her
wherever no I am but it goes beyond
Trump women in general tend to vote
Democrat last election Mitt Romney lost
female voters by a whopping 12 points
and there are more Democrat women in
Congress in fact only 17 Republican
women have ever served in the Senate so
does the Republican Party have girl
trouble do you think that the Republican
Party is a party for women I absolutely
do now what happened to the Republican
Party when there are more women in it
the party blossoms when there are more
women in it do you understand that many
Republican women are very hesitant
actually vote for Trump yeah where that
yeah I do and I think that what would
you say to them I would tell them they
need to get over it and we have blades
have anything to be worried about then
him saying six months ago you in like
early space right just whining whining
yes he's gonna say some things we're all
gonna say some things but at the end of
the day he does represent the party that
also represents
I count what a man does and not what he
says and look at his fucking Morning
Show and his ex-wife says that he was
you know abusive towards her that's
that's redundant I think that women need
to be advocates for themselves we have
rights we need to advocate a lot of the
times we're taught to be victims and why
right now they're saying that being a
woman is a weakness don't make it a
weakness well a lot of women are
actually you know they're hesitant they
also see that the Republican Party is a
party that doesn't believe in let's say
mandated maternity leave so that they
can't get adequate time they need to
raise a family which to them is what
Family Values is about for someone to
say or you shouldn't be Republican
because there's no paid maternity well
that's why we should have more
Republican women out there so that they
can be that voice and they can say well
here's what we're gonna do on the issues
he's gonna be a strong tough president
which is what we need and you think
women need a strong tough yeah man in
their long to be protected we've got
Hillary Clinton her husband and her
disrespect to the office he was having
all kinds of activities I don't want to
say it in the Oval Office and if that's
treating women better then I'm not for
that Trump tweeted like if Hillary can't
please her husband
how can she please America you agree
with that well I don't agree if going
into the bedroom with with all that
stuff I don't you were just there could
you kind of hand it to Hillary for you
know maybe having the biggest balls out
of any candidate I mean if any of those
women candidates are gonna have balls it
would probably be Hillary yes so green
there you have it conservative women
doing it for themselves unless a big
strong man wants to do it for them